welcome back just days after not
saying's conviction was vacated Heyman
Lee's family and says he should be sent
back to prison science case Rose to Fame
in 2014 when the podcast cereal broke
listening records the investigative
series cast doubt on sale's 2000
conviction for the murder of his
ex-girlfriend 18 year old Heyman Lee
since he was arrested back in 1999 Syed
has maintained his innocence he spent
more than 20 years behind bars last week
a Maryland judge ruled to vacate science
conviction saying State evidence in the
original investigation wasn't handed
over to the defense and that two murder
suspects were cleared that should not
have been Heyman Lee's family is now
appealing the judge's decision based on
their rights as victims arguing the
hearing violated their rights as victims
to meaningfully participate in the
proceeding during the hearing Lee's
brother spoke via Zoom but argues he
wanted to speak in person
Terry what law in Maryland sorry is
allowing the victim's family to appeal
like this and what exactly is the Lee
family appealing
so Brian under the Maryland code of
criminal procedure a crime Victor who is
not a party to this proceeding that
victim can ask an appellate court to
review any final order that could
violate their rights and so the review
would be conducted by the Maryland Court
of special appeals it's interesting
they're claiming that they didn't have
notice to vacate science conviction and
that they want it to appear and they did
ultimately appear I suspect that they
will have other reasons to go before
that appellate court and they'll justify
because it was just a short order that
they did in that notice so we'll see
what else they have to say yeah now Josh
how will this affect Syed and is the
depth the DNA evidence the prosecution
is waiting for strong enough to decide
this case one way or another
I don't think this will have much of an
effect on say it's case at all because
we're talking about totally different
things right whether or not the victims
were afforded the proper rights that
they should have been and had an ability
to have their voice heard in court is an
entirely different question as to
whether or not there is enough evidence
to hold this man uh to answer for these
murders and to continue to hold him in
custody and if the prosecution no longer
has confidence in their case then they
shouldn't be affected by whether or not
the victims had a right to be heard in
spite of that being unfortunate uh as
far as this DNA evidence goes you know
time will tell we'll see exactly what it
is but I have to imagine or you hope
that the prosecution took that into
consideration before making their
decision to withdraw his conviction so
it you would imagine that the the
evidence uh doesn't play as great a role
in their determination of whether or not
he's connected to these murders and I
suspect that we will see that they won't
bring a prosecution in this case like
you said time will tell we'll keep eyes
on that decision when we come back
Tennessee defendant Ezekiel Kelly now
faces nearly 30 30 charges following the
mobile mass murder in Memphis which left
three dead and several others injured
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily
kidnapped and slain Tennessee jogger
Eliza Fletcher died from her gunshot
wound to the Head according to the newly
released autopsy results please say the
34 year old mother of two was kidnapped
while jogging near the University of
Memphis in the early morning hours on
September 2nd her body was found three
days later in a field near an abandoned
home officials connected 38 year old
cleotha absent Henderson to the crime
through DNA he was arrested and charged
with Fletcher's kidnapping and murder
surveillance video reportedly caught the
kidnapping on camera absent Henderson
had previously served 20 years in a
separate kidnapping case according to
the autopsy report released Thursday
Fletcher died of a single gunshot wound
to the back of her head little report
says she was shot from an indeterminate
range and that a shell casing was found
near her body it also States Fletcher
suffered blunt foreign my injuries to
her head and to each of her legs absent
Henderson was not has not yet entered a
plea in the case
also in Memphis the man accused of
killing three people and shooting
several others during an hours-long
mobile mass shooting earlier this month
is indicted on an additional 26 charges
following the Rampage Ezekiel Kelly now
faces nearly 30 charges in the September
7th shooting spree which left the
defendant's friends 24 year old Duane
Tunstall Allison Parker and Richard
Clark dead along with three others shot
and injured up up until now Kelly faced
just one count of first-degree murder
this week Kelly was indicted on 26
additional charges including two more
accounts of first-degree murder five
counts of reckless endangerment four
counts of attempted murder attempted
carjacking robbery among several other
charges earlier this week Kelly appeared
in court for a hearing though none of
his Witnesses who were set to testify
showed up the judge signed warrants for
their arrest Kelly's next court hearing
is set for October 18th
Josh how does a criminal defendant end
up with more charges after a grand jury
than before and these charges make sense
you have to remember that a grand jury
is essentially a probable cause hearing
and what happens is the prosecution
brings in all of their evidence presents
that to the grand jury and asks them to
return indictments on what they feel
that they've been able to prove so going
into that they may have only charged him
with one count but the evidence that
they've presented in front of the grand
jury was enough to bring back all of
these other charges now whether or not
he actually pleads to all of those
charges or whether or not he actually
goes to trial and he's convicted on all
those charges is another thing because
the probable cause hearing is simply
that it's a hearing where it's
determined that there's probable cause
to have hold him to answer for these
charges and they believe that they have
enough evidence to at least reach that
standard and yes these charges do make
sense when you're talking about this
type of a rampage that took place where
several shots were fired you can imagine
why you might see attempt murder charges
and other types of assault charges that
we're seeing in this case absolutely now
Terry earlier this year Tennessee
governor Bill Lee paused all execution
scheduled for 2022 for independent
review of the protocols will this effect
if the prosecution seeks the death
penalty here
you know I think they're going to think
twice about seeking the death penalty
but I think they might just proceed
forward because this is why this is a
heinous murder like Josh was just saying
this involved multiple deaths it was
thought out and it was well planned and
you know I think that this is just a
pause it's not overturning the death
sentence in Tennessee and we've seen
this before we saw it out in California
governor Newsom did it and the
prosecutors in that state still sought
it so I think they might here too all
right we'll see how they continue and I
agree with you as well well thank you
Josh and Terry and thank you for joining
us here on Law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]